home alone is undeniably a Christmas
classic how could anyone not love it it
tells the story of a young boy Kevin
McCallister who's accidentally left
behind when his family leaves for a
Christmas vacation to make matters worse
two burglars have targeted the McAlister
house while Kevin is there by himself
unfortunately that's also where things
kind of start to break down kevin
defends his homestead by setting up a
series of elaborate and dangerous traps
in order to stop the bad guys from
robbing the place instead of you know
calling the cops and that's just one of
the many dumb things in home alone that
everyone just ignored call the police
what's the first thing that every kid
learns to do when they realize they're
in danger didn't they teach you that in
school about 911 that somebody needs
help what yeah either Kevin didn't get
the memo or he just doesn't have the
mental capacity of a four-year-old sure
the phone lines are down but he knows
how to get into town to go food shopping
and he knows exactly when Harry and Marv
will be robbing his house Kevin only
Dal's 9-1-1 near the end of the film
after the crooks have made their way
through almost all of his traps even
weirder when he finally calls the cops
he disguises his voice and tells them
his neighbors address why was that the
plan did he think the cops would hear a
child's voice calling for help on 911 or
maybe it's because the cops in this town
suck
he's just home alone come over to the
house see that he's alright just to
check on him you want us to go to your
house just to check on the cops of home
alone are basically garbage with badges
when they're informed about a small
child left without supervision they send
one police officer to the McAlister
house the cop knocks on the door and
then arbitrarily decides Kevin's mom
just can't keep track of her children
because no one answers maybe that's why
the Wet Bandits don't seem concerned in
the slightest when Kevin makes multiple
threats to call the police I'm calling
the cops
wait-wait-wait-wait he wants us to
follow I gotta fit all right here come
on Harry and Marv simply ignore Kevin
and continue to invade his home
they're already guilty of breaking and
entering and they're attempting to
assault a minor so the charges would
probably be pretty severe but because
Kevin lives in a town full of Hall parts
there's really no reason for them to
worry even the pizza boy has lost hope
home alone must happen in some dystopian
alternate reality where the law simply
doesn't matter when Kevin plays the
audio from an old gangster movie to make
the pizza guy think he's about to get
murdered there are absolutely no
consequences
apparently this kid just went back to
delivering more pizzas and never warned
anyone about the spray a gunfire that
just took out half the neighborhood's
inflatable Santa's Marv doesn't know how
TV works the pizza boy scene is weird
but Kevin uses the same trick on Marv as
he tries to break in the back door it
worked on the especially stupid pizza
boy because Kevin only played certain
parts of the conversation making the
pizza boy believe that he was talking to
a real person and we all know the pizza
boys are dumb people said I was dumb but
I'd proved them but when Marv comes to
the door Kevin just plays the movie sure
Kevin adds his own special effects but
as Mark never heard of a TV before how
does this work
why is this happening
Uncle Frank is a monster so we've talked
about how the movie suburban hellscape
is filled with morons but we can't let
Kevin's clan off the hook the
McCallister family is a bunch of hot
garbage while it makes sense that Kevin
might get picked on by his older
siblings and cousins why are the adult
McCallister straight-up bullying an
eight year old when it comes to the
steaming pile of awful human trash that
is this family Uncle Frank
lives at the top when Kevin gets into a
fight with buzz who was pretending to
throw up on Kevin by the way some soda
gets spilled on Uncle Frank's lap Kevin
didn't even do it
it was Kevin's useless dad so naturally
Uncle Frank loses it look what you did
you little jerk
nobody defends Kevin not his parents not
even the kid from Pete and Pete Kevin
you're such a disease
Frank is a middle-aged adult with some
very deep psychological issues forget
Harry and Marv if anyone deserves a nail
through the foot it's Frank the
McCallister's may all be monsters
Kevin's mom has to rush back home
because they can't get in touch with
anybody to look in on Kevin but how is
that possible the entire town didn't go
away for Christmas
Kevin goes to school and even mentions
that he has friends so why can't his
parents call one of their families or
any of the Friends of Kevin's 7,000
siblings is there literally no one in
the entire state of Illinois that the
McAlister
can trust to check up on kevin kevin is
going to kill his family
remember how Harry and Marv kept falling
down the stairs because they were
covered with ice or how the basement
steps were covered in tar and nails
Kevin's massive family was basically
walking into a death trap by the end of
the movie Kevin isn't exactly the most
conscientious kid and he's even pretty
happy about the possibility that he
psychically murdered them I've made my
family disappear so it's incredibly
unlikely the kid cleaned up after
himself
hopefully Uncle Frank cracks his melon
on those icy steps first pizza's here
that's 122 50 oh my brother's house
he'll take care of it your name's Kevin
you know what they're gonna call you in
France don't you huh no yeah uh we
really hate that guy thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to